[Music]
the competition was stiffer than ever on
Tuesdays America's Got Talent
as the remaining acts competed for a
chance to perform in the live shows and
one lucky contestant earned the golden
buzzer I really just want to be my own
artist and make music that people can
relate to
that's chase scoring a 21 year old
singer-songwriter who performed an
original song I told sue for that check
I write songs in my snapback
I don't care what they said Ben Abril
under like in acapella the judges were
awestruck guest judge DJ Khaled was so
moved he did this this show in this
stage is going to make you into a
superstar but chase isn't the only
singer moving on mirror image and Yoli
mayor made it through - so did puddles
pity party oh and thirteen year old Evie
Clare who sang for her dad who was
battling stage four colon cancer we
found out that the tumors in my dad have
grown and that the chemotherapy hasn't
been working
[Music]
also advancing salsa dancing siblings
jr. and Emily and mine reader Colin
cloud think of a unique word to describe
you judge Mel B was stunned when Colin
guessed her word and legitimately
shocked when he took it a step further I
think of myself as a goddess
[Applause]
[Music]
you